- People probably, like,
see my tattoos and piercings
and also, like, my age.
People are like, "Okay,
well you're obviously, like,
spiraling a little bit so
you probably take meds."
(meds rattling in bottle)
(ping, air swooshes)
- Hmm.
- We all look deceiving.
- [Stephen] What does it mean
to look medicated? You know?
- Oh.
- I don't know--
- Well because if you look medicated
you can appear healthy
because you're medicated.
- Or (indistinct)
- Right.
- People probably, like,
see my tattoos and piercings
and also, like, my age.
People are like, "Okay,
well you're obviously, like,
spiraling a little bit so
you probably take meds."
So, I'll be fourth.
- Yeah, I feel like you're middle-ish.
- I guess I'm excited to see
what everyone is going to be.
Like, who's gonna be on
medication, who's not really.
A lot of people don't really present
like they're on medication.
At least a lot of people that
I know, you would never guess
that they were on medication.
- I feel like you'd probably be there,
like, just right before me.
- Oh, like right here? Or
- Yes.
in front of you?
- No. Yeah, like,
right here.
- Okay.
- Can I say, I think I should
move up just a little bit.
- Yeah, no, okay.
- Maybe like right before you.
- I feel like I could be,
like, towards, like, the least.
- Yes. Okay.
- All right. All right.
- Let's just say like the least.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If it's based on appearance
or anything like that, like,
maybe, like, here or there.
- Yeah. I think this
is the right position.
- Okay. I think we're good.
- Sure. You can lock this in.
- Yeah.
- (chuckling) Yeah.
- Okay.
(air swooshing)
- My experience with medication was:
my parents were very much
against it as a child,
but some things happened
and we were, like, "Okay,
he kind of needs it."
- [Fay] Yeah.
- I grew up in a Japanese
household, very traditional.
And so, a lot of times, like,
you would be told, like, "Oh,
if you take, like, these
certain, like, herbal medications
or if you drink certain teas,
like, it can, like, cure a lot
of ailments. I come from, like,
a religious background that isn't, like,
a traditional Christian
or Shintoism or Buddhism.
The philosophy behind
that religion is if you
think something negative it
will manifest physically.
And so a lot of times it came
down to, like, blaming myself
for being sick even if it
wasn't, like, truly my fault.
- I've actually survived a massacre.
Yeah, well I live in Colorado
and there's the theater shooting there.
So, then I was actually
a direct victim of it.
I didn't really get exposed to,
like, medication until,
like, more recently,
but it was kind of, like,
all these underlying issues
that, like, built up since then.
You get, like, really numb when
you're, like, surrounded by,
like, people who are, like,
always worried about you.
You develop, like, almost, like,
a DID or Dissociative Identity Disorder.
It's just kind of, like,
them just throwing stuff
at you and then just being,
like, "Oh, maybe this'll work."
- Were any of you guys
introduced into medication
off of, like, physical injury or mental?
- Injuries or mental issues.
There's also physical like
disability as well, so.
- Yes.
- Like, a little bit of each.
So... (participants chuckle)
- I come from an African household,
also with people in the medical field.
But surprising enough,
I wasn't really, like, introduced to it.
Because everything was,
like, natural remedies
and just like, "Oh, I don't
think it's that serious,
so we'll stay home instead." You know?
- Mm-hmm.
- When I was younger, like,
my parents, like, were okay
with me, like, taking stuff
for my physical needs.
As I got older,
they were very against medication
for, like, mental health
at first and I think still,
honestly, my parents
are against medication
for, like, mental health.
- So there's also physical,
like, disability as well.
So, it's kind of,
- Yes.
like, a chain reaction
with some of these things
that, like, one thing
caused another thing,
which caused injury.
- Mm.
- So that in that injury caused a need
for medication 'cause
it caused another thing.
- I only recently got my
first, I guess, medication
when I was 15.
It was really hard for me to,
I guess, accept that I needed help.
I'm not someone that
really likes help but when
it came to just like
doing certain daily tasks
that I needed to do, like,
I needed something to,
like, help me, I guess, regulate that.
'Cause I was definitely going down
a path that was not a good one.
(participants talking simultaneously)
- I feel like you might be a little ahead.
- Maybe. Yeah.
- Okay.
- I really think you're, like, less.
(participants talking simultaneously)
- I feel like he's good.
- No, I--
- I think he's good.
- I think I should move up.
I really think I should.
- Yeah, you seem confident
- I don't--
about being higher.
- Yeah, but, I don't think I'm
the top.
- Okay.
- You know?
I'm on the top
right now, so.
- So you're just being modest?
- Do you think you're the most medicated?
- I feel like, I don't know.
I think it may be between
you and me right now.
(air swooshing)
- Okay. For me, I've had Anxiety
throughout my whole life.
Elementary school, all of
middle school up until,
like, freshman year of high school,
end of it is when I got
a diagnosis of ADHD.
- Based off, like, what
you said, I would probably
put you, I guess, put you
somewhere... Maybe here?
- Yeah. I would probably be on this side.
- Okay.
- Maybe.
- I actually was left undiagnosed
for almost like a decade.
It was, like, until this
year I was just, like, "Man,
I can't focus on a
single thing," you know,
panic attacks and other stuff.
So I actually went to the
therapist under victim comp.
Pretty much, they diagnosed me with,
you know, the holy trinity:
ADHD, depression/anxiety
and then PTSD, of course.
I came from a culture where it's just,
like, you don't want to bother people.
And that's, like, what my
mom always would tell me
is just, like, "Don't bother someone else.
Don't bother someone else."
I think that's another thing
that kind of empowered the sort
of numbing - everyone grieving for you
and you don't want them to
and you don't wanna be
in that position where,
like, you have to tell them that it's okay
and that you're, like,
still there and then just
trying to comfort them rather
than them comforting you.
- I think that you should go ahead
and cha cha your way to the front.
- All right.
- Cha cha.
- (chuckling) Oh my god.
- I had mental health problems
growing up as a child.
I actually had, like, really
severe OCD and it went
undiagnosed for a really long time.
I have Major Depressive Order and Anxiety.
So I got diagnosed with
that when I was around 20.
But this year I actually got diagnosed
with Gastroparesis. It basically means
that my stomach is either
partially or fully paralyzed.
Let's say for example,
like, let's say your stomach
is done digesting, like, four
hours. Let's say that, right?
My stomach will take
eight hours, for example.
And usually it doesn't contract,
it just uses acid alone.
And so sometimes, I kinda like
joke about this, but, like,
it's not super funny, but
sometimes I'm like, "Oh,
if you guys wanna see
a magic trick, give me,
like, an hour and I could
throw my food back up whole."
- Bleh.
- Oh my goodness gracious.
- Yeah.
- Wow. Wow.
- I don't wanna say a magic
trick, but that's very
interesting.
- Yeah, no,
thank you for offering though.
- Yeah. (participants
laugh, speak indistinctly)
I'll keep it here.
Well, I do think she's
more medicated than I am.
- Okay yeah. So then,
- So.
you go get in front of
Kevin then, for now.
- I like how we're just putting
everyone just in the middle
(chuckling) right after
we hear their story.
It's just, like, "Alright."
- I'm back.
- I was diagnosed with
ADHD when I was six.
I was off medication
for a while because when
I was 11 I was diagnosed with
Restrictive Cardiomyopathy
which is a disorder in the heart.
And a year later I got a heart transplant.
- I feel like you might be higher then...
Because I was just--
- I agree.
- I am inclined to move
up or stay up higher.
- I wanna, I think we should
hear your thing first.
- So I have Major Depressive
Disorder, and Anxiety, and PTSD
but I've also struggled
with addiction and I'm...
I'll be three years sober on November 2nd.
- Yay!
- Congrats!
- Oh my goodness!
- The last thing I wanna talk about
is I also have a rare chronic illness.
It's kinda like Narcolepsy.
It's called, like, Idiopathic Hypersomnia.
And I basically feel like I haven't slept
for 24 to 48 hours every single day.
But there's only one medication
that's FDA approved for it.
So it's been a struggle
but I'm finally able to,
like, hold a job and I'm
going to school also.
So, yeah.
- I feel like she should be
in front of me but behind her.
- I feel like you should be
either above me or next to me.
- Yeah. The only reason
why is 'cause I feel,
like, a lot of the stuff
that you're dealing
with also includes a lot
of more verbal therapy.
- I wanna hear your story
because I don't think
I'm the most medicated
but I can't get a read, you know?
- I think the first diagnosis I got was,
like, Anxiety/Depression
but they didn't do any sort
of psychiatric testing.
They just kind of looked
at me and they were like,
"Man, weird." Vasavegal
Syncope, Aerophagia.
I just recently got diagnosed
with Autism and ADHD.
That's all I'll say, and
that's quite enough I think.
- [Producer] Do you guys
want to be medicated?
- I don't want to take medicine.
It's hard to keep up with, you know?
It's like paying a subscription to live.
- As long as they're giving
me a better quality of life
and, better as a person,
and wanna live, then
I wanna take my meds.
When I first started getting
sober, I was in a rehab
and they prescribed me like a whole bunch
of different medications.
But I believe that
without those medications
for my addiction that I
wouldn't be sober today.
So it, like, really helped save my life.
- I want having to take medications to be,
like, the last resort and I wanna go
through all the possible
things that I could do before.
I feel like we're all aware
that the more medicine
that doctors, you know, give you,
the more money they're making.
So I dunno, it's like a
trust issue type of thing.
But also, like, if I really need it,
like, of course, like,
for pain and whatnot.
But again, let's go through
all the things that, you know,
I could do, and if those don't
work for, like, helping me?
All right then gimme the pills.
- So obviously I don't
want to be on medication
'cause it costs money, but
I'm not a big fan of medical
but I've never personally
had a bad experience
but I know that that's not
the case for most people.
- 'Cause no, Dylan, you trust it.
So...
- Yeah.
- (chuckling) Hey, like
you have the trust.
So be before me.
- I trust it
but maybe I don't like, you know,
certain side effects from
certain things, you know?
I was unmedicated for 15 to 18 years,
depending on how you look at it.
I feel like I'm probably lower than you.
There's a a high chance.
- I'm okay with this.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Good structure.
- I'm good.
- Okay, we're good.
(participants simultaneously) Locked in.
(air swooshing)
- [Producer] In seventh, Mary.
- Okay.
- [Producer] In sixth, Dylan.
- Hey guys.
- [Producer] In fifth, Kevin.
Fourth, Elizabeth.
Third, Joyce.
Second, Stephen.
- Okay.
- Wow.
- I knew it.
- [Producer] So now what we're gonna do,
we're gonna go through
how many medications you
guys are actually taking.
- Oh perfect. Love that for me.
- This would a be good reference video
I could show the doctors real quick
in appointments when they
need to get the list.
That's the most annoying part of it.
- I guess down the line again?
- [Producer] Yeah, we'll start with Mary.
- Okay, well, I take no medications.
I feel like if I've went all
those years being unmedicated
and still fine, I'm still here living,
I could do, you know,
a couple more decades.
I will definitely continue to keep going
down the holistic path but it's also
I'm open to medications.
- I take one medication.
Take Vyvanse for ADHD.
It just helps me with
impulse control and all that.
- I'm actually on three medications.
This is, like, the thing
that's mainly changing
is the antidepressants.
Of course, you know Adderall for the ADHD.
And when I'm too wired they
also put me on Trazodone.
So it's pretty much just,
like, "Here's an upper,
here's a downer and
here's, like, something
so you don't feel depressed."
- I take five. I take,
this is called Zofran.
I also take this one.
This is called Remron.
This is Ativan. I also
take a Scopolamine patch
and then my last one, which
is my primary medication,
Motilium. This one is
actually not legal in the USA.
It's not FDA approved,
and the reason for that
is because it causes a high
chance of a heart attack
and stroke. So, I get EKGs
done just to make sure
that I'm still within safe levels.
- [Producer] Would you be able
to survive without that medication?
- Currently, no, because it's
the only known medication
to treat, like, my condition.
Without it, there's a
good chance I'll have to
stay hospitalized for fluids and liquids.
I could not not sustain myself.
I basically was diagnosed
recently with Gastroparesis.
You can even identify it as
like a really mild form of,
like, organ failure.
My stomach either is fully
paralyzed or partially paralyzed.
And so, the way I digest,
I rely on the acid
in my stomach and I can't
rely on the mechanics of it.
- I take seven. I don't
have that many meds guys.
So I also take Zofran.
I take this as needed.
I also take something called Armodafinil.
I take Clonidine at night.
I also take Bupropion or
Wellbutrin for my depression.
Something called Synthroid.
And last one is just Aciclovir
for a virus that I have
and I take this every single day.
- So I take eight medications.
First is one of the main ones, Tacrolimus,
better known as Prograf.
Another immunosuppressor is Sirolimus.
And then a lot of medications are just
to quell side effects of these two.
First is Diltiazem. Atorvastatin,
also known as Lipitor.
I forgot exactly what this one does.
Bayer Aspirin. Lisinopril.
I also take Adderall.
Last one, I promise.
This is Vitamin D3.
That's everything.
(cheers, applause, whistle sounds)
Yeah!
- This one is a Xulane patch.
This is a birth control.
This is the fifth birth
control I've been on.
This is Topamax. This is
both for chronic migraines,
and also, I got a higher dosage
because I developed motor ticks.
Midodrine is the one
medication I am on for fainting
for my blood pressure.
Here we got Gabapentin. I
just got prescribed this one
for, like, panic attacks and stuff
and also for chronic pain.
But Juniper got prescribed the same thing.
Cymbalta. This is Imatrex for emergency
for really bad migraines.
This is a nasal spray for allergies.
This is a inhaler. And
then this is Singulair.
And then Aerophagia, like an acid reducer.
- Wow we could be, like, an
ad for Big Pharma right now.
(mellow tune plays)
I don't know, I feel
like sometimes I have to,
like, justify my problems to be like, "No,
it actually is something
that is a problem."
I had an employer when
I first got diagnosed
and he was actually,
like, really rude about it
and he told, like, everybody like,
"Oh, she's probably just pregnant."
People won't always, like, look at you
and think, like, "You
are definitely somebody
who is medicated," you know?
- I just wish people could see that, like,
just 'cause you can't see an illness,
just 'cause it's invisible
doesn't mean it doesn't exist.
- [Producer] Do you have any
final thoughts you'd like to
impart on someone who
might be watching this?
- I mean, I really just think
it just speaks to, like,
you can't tell anything
about someone just by looking at them.
Except for the fact
that everybody was like,
"You are the most medicated,"
as soon as I walked in,
and they were correct.
So, I guess, for me, maybe they can
(chuckling) but for everybody
else you can't tell.